good evening everyone so it's hamza said
my name is Jakob to introduce a bit
myself I'll try to make it a bit smaller
I'm a Python software /data engineers
like scientists now working at want line
you're a trading company we run our own
trading platform most of the code base
is Python and as Yun said my roots are
rather long in in academia and I was
doing mostly numerical simulation in
fusion research and today I'll it's my
pleasure to talk about Titan
optimization for numerical calculations
so peyten
is slow this is what I hear many times
and the question I pose the way it is it
really and the answer is it depends and
and also the answer is even if it's low
we can optimize when appropriate and now
I'll try to give you some some
motivation and some overview of how you
can actually do that now you've heard
maybe that premature optimization is the
root of all evil
that's a frequently cited phrase and
it's it's kind of true so follow that
because you of course you need to assess
you need to know that if before you
optimize you need to decide what to
optimize for typically you have to trade
the total cost which are the development
called human work the computer time and
your gain is your profit so don't try to
optimize too early with an unknown goal
so what are the typical optimization
goals is we often think of faster
execution so less CPU time spending in
the calculation we should also think
about less memory consumption
it can be because that can bring
resources like in even in terms of money
even in a cloud of you need to buy the
hardware and we should also look into
how the performance chaos with the
problem size so those are I think the
three main things to optimize for and
also one nice thing to remember always
is that there is a partial principle
which states that 80% of the effects
come from 20% of the causes or you can
change the numbers a bit but for coded
me it means that basically 80% of your
CPU time is it's been in something like
20% of the source code so your goal is
to identify these 20% first and then to
optimize those 20% and on forget to
consult xkcd of course so to actually
identify the 20% the tool you would use
is a profiler so here I give you just a
short list of tools you that can be
useful I'm not going to touch this topic
too much or basically not at all so just
keep it for reference and instead what I
I assume that we've already found a good
reason to optimize something and we'll
do that here to get today and the target
of our optimization today is a numerical
calculation if one way to optimize is
something different like o alikum
general Python code the tools would be
different
it might overlap but in general it could
be quite different so there is a test
example which I actually have stolen
from Jake wonder Plus talk but it's now
nothing very special it's a it's a
trillion distance calculation of of a
set of
factors so as I said we are at the point
that we have found that this is the
bottleneck of of our of our business so
let's let's try to optimize that so I'll
start with just some random data as
input which I will use for throughout
the presentation to demonstrate the
performance and the steps that I'm doing
now I I think we probably all or most of
us know that numpy would be the number
one choice to do this kind of
calculation in Python here you see I
think I can make this bigger again so
you see how this is implemented in
Python and one particular thing that is
handy in this case is it's broadcasting
so numpy can kind of automatically
broadcast or extend the dimensions and
then and we use it here to do the
pairwise calculation and some reduction
to actually get the results we want so
it's a it's a one-liner it's really
short and it does to think well now I'm
going to use present time 8 which is an
iPad magic 4 for just getting some
statistics about run time so in the in
the background it would run the the
command that I give it multiple times
and get it will get some some statistics
and I was I'm storing that into into a
dictionary which I would then use to
compare the times so we are at 40
milliseconds for this this case actually
this so these results were just one
before the presentation on my laptop
which is not the newest most performant
one if you run it on
or server or even on a modern desktop
you would get probably low in numbers
and also I'll talk about that later but
you can get different results in terms
of ordering the approaches so let's
let's ask whether what what kind of
performance we get from Python loops if
I if I teach Python which I do at the
University I typically emphasize that
something like for I in range something
is an ends is the typical anti-pattern
and we often do either iteration on some
kind on the list and get the items
themselves but in numerix we do
vectorized operations with numpy but
here I will demonstrate how performant
it is and later I show that it's
actually handy to have this
implementation anyway so here is a loop
loop code that you would that looks like
C codes so for those who are used to
code in C C++ you you would do that and
it would run well now if I run it it
takes five seconds which is way much
slower than the numpy performance so
he'll see a comparison mind that the
y-axis is in log scale so we get
something like two orders of magnitude
difference in runtime
okay so now we can you would answer to
our initial questions that Python is
slow well let's see as you probably know
we should really test that the function
we are implementing is it's doing the
right thing so I'll just put in after
every implementation I just do a simple
assert now we can do that with
by all and compare the numbers it's not
the best idea because we have
floating-point arithmetic so what's
better is to use all clothes but with
with a low tolerance so we are pretty
confident that we are happy with the
result so that's my cert we are happy
function here okay so number three
possibility for the optimizing the coded
the function that I present it is seitan
so seitan is quite a mature tool it's
it's got a lot of features not just a
feature that I would show here
basically what it does it extends the
Python language it was particularly
bye-bye see imports so so kind of sea
level importing libraries then what it
does it translates the the the seitan
source code which you would use with
extension dot PI Y X which comes from
Pyrex which is the language that came
basically before seitan and it
translates it to C and C++ and compiles
it into a Python module so it includes
what that is static typing we make use
of that you can also conveniently code
and unbind
C or C++ and so on so it is very
powerful so if if you just sign eyes the
the function that we implemented and I'm
taking a shortcut here using another
iPad magic with a double percent size
and minus a so I run it on the
implementation now actually switch to
to the notebook view just to give you
show you the output here so the output
if you put - a wood mark by the yellow
color the pieces of the code that are
not optimized that certain things have
too much interaction with Peyton
so already from this color you might
guess that we are not optimizing the
code to to make it better we can we can
static type some of the variables that
are used in the function that's what I
do here with these C deaths and in
particular this one and also on the
interface you see I already put vampire
vampire array so this function now works
only for an umpire two dimensional
arrays and it it uses the static typing
to to see the effect on the color so you
I think if you compare if you remember a
bit that picture before was much more
yellow
now you're getting less yellow which is
good so Satan doesn't like hello by the
way if also if you analyze this there is
this plus sign and button and you can
actually see what what amount of work
your your python interpreter is doing
internally to get you the very nice
language and the high abstractions that
we all love and that we use to code very
fast okay
so let's test these two functions okay
I've done that before so believe me it
really been well and see
performance so actually the first
version or the zero version is a little
bit slower okay it's on par with the
Python version which is what you should
expect in this case it's not in general
that if you run the seitan on your on
your Python code you would not gain a
performance it's just because we are we
we have just a tiny function where we
just don't get anything now the the
second version so version 1 is it's
already quite faster it's in between the
loops and numpy version so we are
probably in the right direction and if
you then look into the usual tricks that
PI that Satan offers for this color this
calculation this optimization you would
find it if you switch off checking the
array bounds and if and disabling
negative indexing so you switch off some
of the fancy nice features that we have
from Titan and numpy what you get is
less yellow which is good here comes and
if you look where the yellow lines are
now you probably don't see it really but
these are just the yellow lines that we
can get rid of because we just need to
interact with Titan somehow and we need
to deliver Titan objects back and import
numpy and so on
and what we actually gain is a
performance that is much faster than
numpy and I think that's a that's a huge
game
so we've beaten numpy by an order of
magnitude by doing starting with a dumb
style for loops and but by then by just
adding a couple lines of sight in
decorator and Static typing yeah so we
are really happy with that
okay maybe someone will tell you okay
you should do it in Fortran that's like
the language for doing for doing numerix
and it will just beat your fighting
suddenly so let's try we we are lucky
that numpy guys very so smart that they
created this F 2 pi code that they
people use a lot to rep Fortran or C so
then let's not be shy and do some
Fortran and I actually like the Fortran
at least the modern for time it's it's
not it's not a bad language so the
implementation for this case looks
pretty much like the Python loops I mean
you might you can spot the nice double
precision wording so that's that's the
Fortran way of doing stuff so
okay so the there's not that much work
that we need to do to actually get a
Python module out of that code so we run
F 2 pi we use actually sums which is
that we don't need so we just put have 2
pi we read the documentation v and we
know that we just put this the the
source code file name and minus M the
name of the module and it should should
run and if you then import the module
and look at the documentation of the of
the function that you just compiled you
would see the interface so F 2 pi
actually understood the dimensionality
the types and it would report you that
in in the documentation so it seems the
interface is what we actually need and
we can test if if it runs well one thing
to remember is that Fortran uses a
different ordering than C so to get the
best performance you should you should
have DD Fortran or drink in your
matrices or arrays now it runs it's a
the the time here is under 7
milliseconds I'll show you the
comparison in the in the plots but when
I see this it's quite different than
what I get on on my laptop and it's here
we are touching the quite some some
low-level properties of your hardware so
it and then the compiling switches and
so on so you might even want to tune the
compilation further and then so this was
Fortran and the the last two I'll show
you here briefly its number and I really
like it it's it's a super simple tool to
use and pretty powerful it does not do
all everything it's not almighty
but it does it basically it uses LLVM on
the bottom it's built for data and
science so for us and it's
straightforward to use and what it and
it compiles your Python code into a
machine code so for our use case we can
just take number dot cheat which is just
in time compiler decorator there's a
couple of options are used to defaults
for for now what one particular
interesting one is it's no Python which
sounds scary but it's it really compiles
fighting but internally it would refuse
to run any code that depends on the
Python runtime it would fail for out for
our case by the way but it's there is
work around you not too difficult to to
make it work but there's there's no gain
on the performance so what I do here I
just decorate my loops function so again
not the numpy one and then compile it or
just-in-time compile it with number it's
the same as you know seitan it works of
course I would not show you if it did
not so the time is now comparable if I
remember well to seitan the best seitan
so here goes
so we have seitan to number just very
fast compared to the others Fortran
following but when I rented today on the
laptop for ten was I think the second
number was the first one and seitan the
third one so don't draw too many
conclusions from the ordering of the
these three two three okay so I think
we've done pretty good business on
optimizing that
small functions more function now
I also said we should look at the memory
usage here I'm using a tool from our
speaker from the last pi PI data Meetup
and I would just watch the memory using
this tool and okay here in the bottom I
run it from my original X array which is
not too large but it's a thousand times
3
it doesn't seem it doesn't take any
memory especially the peak memory is 0
that's good now when I try to run that
on a little bit larger problem so 5
times and sometimes and so I call it
Excel here and run it on Excel if you
can see it from over there there is a
peaked memory of 1 gigabyte which can be
a little bit unexpected
it's from the broadcasting thing so if
you think about what broadcasting does
it adds one more dimension and so it
creates a potentially huge huge array
and then if you just add a instead of 10
and 4 instead of 5 and 2 you would add a
little bit more elements you would run
out of your memory if you are not
running on a on a big computer so be
careful with that and actually if you
look at what number version does is that
it takes it it solves this issue for you
and it's kind of comes out from the
solution you are not doing you're not
constructing the big the big array you
are just looping so there's another
problem solve by number sighting would
be the same here
because it's doing the ended looping
similarly
sorry so yeah the first quote is from
this presentation so feel free to cite
it from now on okay so I think
parallelization is kind of comes along
with optimization it can be a way to
make your call run faster my my advice
is is try to use what's available as
much as possible try to be on rather on
the high level don't do the low level
parallelization although I'll show you
the low level to vary more typically you
need to run something like a map on on a
number of inputs so you can use you
don't need to paralyze the internal of
the code and also avoid threats
I'll show you threat again or that we
can use threats but the advice is don't
try to do it yourself if you're not well
aware of what you are doing on also
because the unfamous Gil which would
prevent you from doing reading but it's
actually helping you not doing terrible
mistakes right
so in in peyten in the standard lab
there's a module called concurrent
features if you read the documentation
there's there's not too many not too
much stuff in there you find two basic
classes executors which is something
that would execute as following the name
would say the functions on in either
effect pool or process pool or you or
any pool that other libraries can can
expose and there is there's desk or a PI
parallel which are quite well-known
maybe less known is that there's also
MPI for pi which is a message passing
library for Python which also exposes an
executor that's fairly interesting and
then you have the future class which is
an asynchronous Bazaar the promise of
result which is returned by a by the
executor so just a simple example I
won't use it for our problem now and
I'll actually probably make it very fast
because I'm running out of time but
close to the end so if so the parallel
map if you have a number of inputs you
want to map a function on just use an
executor that is suitable for you now
that pool might be usable I'm using it
here now because it's the simplest one
to spin off but it might not deliver you
any parallelization it can though
especially with numpy find us
they often release your evil Gil so they
you can make use of threads if you are
using those libraries then you so what
you get is is are those future results
and typically you somehow need to
synchronize you need to wait for them so
there is there's wait function in
concurrent futures and then once these
are done you can just collect results in
in a list for example as I'm doing here
there is also a map map method of the
executor which would do about the same
but we just eat in a generator so you
you would work with that a little bit
differently you would not get the
futures themselves here and I already
mentioned the I asked and I fight for
well that offer very easy to use
scalable cluster executors which can
either run on your local machine or can
even run on a cluster and so you just
run on your colleagues laptops you just
want one single command and you can get
a cluster out of your office in in a
minute or so this is I think what I just
said so let me skip that and now a
little bit on paralyzing the code that
we actually targeted today I'll use
number again there is a parallel
argument to JIT which does what it says
it that is try to fertilize the code you
should also use P range so a parallel
range instead of range and issues you
should see if the code is easily
parallelizable with which is our case an
increase of performance so usage of more
courses at the same time I mentioned MPI
for PI a side of exactly two you can of
course use it for
large-scale scenarios where you need to
send messages typically short messages
in and out from from a pool of processes
potentially across your your large
cluster and it makes it easy to send
some Python objects it's also performing
for numpy arrays and you don't have to
use the raw MPI protocol which is rather
simplistic and there's just primitive
types that you can you can use and also
such a just briefly what task offers in
its high high level collections and can
also do some parallelization so
for number it takes just the same jet
with parallel equals to and replacement
of the first range by P range if you go
through the through the loop you would
see that you can really make the the
inside of the first loop or even the
second one independent it doesn't matter
how will be how its ordered and if you
do that you assert that you are happy
you execute the parallel version or time
the parallel version you can get times
that are really faster then your
previous number run so it makes use of
your threads or course efficiently with
almost zero effort that's another good
result I think and now just really fast
crawl through desk I'll show you how
array which is one of the high-level
collection can be used what it is but
please consult the documentation or the
desk tutorial to learn more so here I
create an array collection so that would
be a desk version of an umpire array
right it's made for out of core
distributed calculations since we will
use it for for a small problem it's not
really helping us but we can see the
principles one of the principles you
need to follow is that you you specify
how large chunks of the data you have so
and once you create that object you have
this delayed function or decorator that
that you use and that desk uses to to
actually create a call graph instead of
executing functions and then executing
the call graph
so this is what how you can create a
delayed function from an existing
function but if we do actually want to
implement our pairwise function we can
just plug in the desc array into the
place where we have our numpy array and
it would create a call graph which and
we can do it step by step in fact so I'm
taking the first step here so you see it
with chunk into two and then schedule
the the calculation planning calculation
okay so there's two more steps with some
and square root here is the final graph
you check that it's doing the right
thing and actually the time it takes
here on a local computer is slower but
not not too much slower than the number
then the site inversion so it in
principle should scale better for large
arrays especially if they don't fit into
your memory it would be able to do it so
this is the way if you want if you need
to scale for for larger problems and I'm
not going to show this because
I would like to end with this slide
already so my summary is you use Python
for numerics there's powerful tools that
exist for optimizing calculations you
can have very efficient optimization
with and with a little effort with the
JIT decorator phone number be careful
with numpy memory consumption in in if
it's doing broadcasting by the way there
was a koala fall from west makini the
author of pandas and his rule of thumb
is that your memory should be something
like five to ten times larger than the
size of your pandas dataframe which is
what people might not guess but if they
come to pandas and then one of the
reason is reasons is of course this
because not numpy is used heavily in in
pandas also remember congruent features
if you have not have not found that yet
in your python library look it up use it
and for referring to this these slides
it's all available on github for free
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
there's some similar cheese for sure
there is a lot of tools that would
actually construct a call graph and then
execute it on engine and workers if you
look into spark it would be similar also
so tensorflow I think is different in
that sense that you have more emphasis
on tensor algebra in in your in the
nodes of the graph while here it's
that's would have also the algebra but
you can also put arbitrary fighting
functions
or Fortran yeah so the question is to
compare the performance or because well
I think the answer is it depends again
because as I showed here you can you can
be on par with a Fortran code which i
think is a spectacular almost Fortran
would be on the similar speed as C the
coding would take you much more time if
you do it if you start from C for sure
so this is my one of my first advices is
because in fighting if you are a decent
Python programmer you would code fast
prototype fast you find your bottlenecks
first and then you can fall back to
either some of these tools and even
maybe Fortran C C++ Java is a bit
difficult to interface to Python so with
Java you are the drifting out of this
meetup I could not work
[Laughter]
use number for everything the optimal
tool to do everything or is there any
like now we can't use it we certainly
can't use it for everything and now I
think the way to use it is to localize
what needs to be made fast and then
compile that back piece one of the
reasons is that seeing errors from from
a number optimized function is more
difficult than from fighting so if you
don't need that performance don't
decorate it don't use seitan and number
at least at this stage it's not
replacing seitan completely there is
there's a lot of features that Satan has
and number does not yeah there was
actually a discussion on my one of the
function that I'm profiling basically
and I'm not using Wi-Fi
I admit that maybe I should try it more
often but the reason I'm not using Wi-Fi
is the lack of all the numpy ecosystem
so pi pi is awesome it's got a lot of
just-in-time compilation features if you
run if you if you implement that code
and actually thanks to people that are
sitting somewhere around here it did the
benchmark just before so just in time
before before we started this meetup it
runs very fast if you implemented in
Python using lists and running on pi PI
which is very good it even even Titan
can run faster than in indexing numpy
arrays but numpy would then
it would not scale up or out if you like
all the numpy bound tools and that the
algebra that already is in numpy and the
tools around so I think that's still a
shortcoming of pipe I not sure if it can
be resolved but I'm not that much of an
expert on pipe I
[Applause]